once upon a time American actor and
martial artist Wesley Snipes was the
most in-demand action star in show
business and for good reason
Snipes unique ability to be both
athletic and charming led to some very
successful performances these days
however Hollywood doesn't seem to give
him much work anymore and here's why
hitting it big Wesley Snipes career got
off to a blazing start when he landed
the role of Willie Mays Hayes the
swift-footed bass dealer and the
baseball comedy classic major league but
while that showcase of quick wit might
have been a home run with casting
directors he led his overnight fame get
to his head a little too quickly plan to
put on a hitting display Snipes
reportedly turned down the chance to
star in the sequel major league 2 which
ticked off some of his co-stars Corbin
Bernsen for one set of the discs I said
hey man they're gonna make major league
2 and he was like you're gonna do that
and I thought wow how quickly they
forget
he'd become Wesley Snipes that rubbed me
the wrong way
although Snipes had earned the ire of
his major league team he did earn quite
a few grand slams right out of the
dugout including jungle fever white men
can't jump passenger 57 demolition man
and murder at 1600 but while he was
never a critical darling
despite his box office prowess his
career started to cool once a pattern of
legal problems began to emerge facing
handcuffs
Snipes first brush with the law wasn't
his fault in 1981 he was arrested while
driving a car leased by his production
company and claimed he was assaulted and
humiliated by the police as a result of
racial profiling but Snipes second major
run-in with the law was brought on this
time by legitimate reasons and would put
it dead in the actors professional
reputation in August 1993 Snipes was
arrested for carrying a concealed weapon
loaded with half a dozen rounds of
hollow-point bullets after a fender
bending motorcycle accident in Hollywood
Snipes received two years of
unsupervised probation and was fined
$2,700 the following year
Snipes reputation as a law-abiding
citizen decreased even further when the
actor led a Florida State Trooper on a
120 mile per hour high-speed chase which
ended in the action star crashing his
motorcycle
Snipes got off with a citation for
reckless
driving and refused medical treatment
but his reputation was immediately
damaged by the unusual incident bouncing
back just when it seemed like Snipes
run-ins with the law
and a string of less than stellar
performances were on the brink of
completely bankrupting his career the
action star bounced back with his most
iconic role yet the title vampire
slaying superhero and blade despite
receiving only mediocre critical reviews
the film was a massive success spawning
a pair of sequels and cementing Snipes
as both a household name and a bonafide
action hero after the commercial success
of blade Snipes career was on the
upswing again unfortunately for him that
second rise was followed by an even
bigger fall falling again after blade
the actor starred in a string of films
that failed to court the same kind of
audience as his earlier fix first up was
the art of war which was a massive
failure both critically and commercially
then there was zigzag and undisputed
which dug the hole even deeper the final
nail in the coffin for Snipes was blade
Trinity in addition to being the least
liked film in the series he all but
ensured major studios would never work
with Snipes again especially after
Snipes filed a lawsuit against New Line
Cinema and the filmmakers to the tune of
5 million dollars
Snipes alleged the filmmakers and
supporting cast were all approved
without his express consent which
violated his contract he also claimed
writer director David Goyer made racist
remarks regarding Snipes professionalism
and refused to punish a crew member who
wore a racist t-shirt while filming on
top of that
Snipes claimed New Line Cinema
intentionally hired only white
individuals still owed him three million
dollars and didn't help the actor obtain
a tax exemption
co-star Patton Oswalt however claimed
that Snipes was a problem during
production and Wesley Snipes was going
crazy and he would come out of his
trailer and he would only answer to the
name blade after that Oswalt said
Snipes attempted to force David Goyer to
resign from the film but his biggest
problems were only beginning to take
shape
Uncle Sam slam perhaps the most
notorious reason Wesley Snipes career
soured is that he was convicted on three
demeanor counts for failing to file
three years worth of tax returns which
apparently cheated Uncle Sam out of
seven million dollars
the prosecution blamed Snipes for
following the advice of both his
accountants and another firm anti-tax
proponent Snipes who had already paid
millions of dollars in taxes was
sentenced to three years in prison in
2008
before being transferred to the New York
Community Corrections office for home
confinement as soon as stipes got out of
prison the IRS piled on the civil tax
collections arguing that the actor owed
them close to 18 million dollars Snipes
decided he had had enough and filed a
lawsuit against the government's tax
collection agency stipes argued that the
IRS was just arbitrarily throwing out
figures in an effort to collect as much
money as possible time for a turnaround
those types doesn't get very many big
time movie offers anymore he still gets
plenty of small-time movie offers most
recently he starred in 2017 armed
response and the recall he also had a
role in the Expendables 3 which served
to put Snipes name back into a
big-budget film even more promising
Snipes played Cyclops in Spike Lee's
chiraq which is undoubtedly the best
project to involve the actor in recent
decades he's also shown a new interest
in dancing and musical theater lately so
doing movies was cool but it still
wasn't fulfilling what I really wanted
to do if a choice between doing a movie
and doing a dance show I'll do the dance
first on top of that he's also been busy
writing what he hopes will ultimately be
a trilogy of books the first of which
talent of God is on shelves now all
things considered it's not time to ride
off Wesley Snipes not yet thanks for
watching click the looper icon subscribe
to our YouTube channel let's check out
all this cool stuff we know you'll love
to
you
[Music]